David and Tamara are with us hey guys
how are ya pretty good how you doing
here welcome welcome good to have you
right where are you guys from
we're from like the Ozarks in Missouri
oh absolutely very cool beautiful area
it is very nice welcome to Nashville and
you're here to do your debt-free screen
we are waited four years
over four years to be right here so I
love it how much have you paid off we
have paid off two hundred and eighty one
thousand nine hundred fifty six dollars
and ninety one says goodness and that
took how long four years and eight
months four years and eight months
making what kind of money during that
time it ranged between 95 thousand and
up to one hundred and fifty way to go
what do you guys do for a living I'm a
UPS driver uh-huh and I deliver your
books all the time to people in Missouri
oh cool thank you all right we
appreciate that yeah we're a fairly
large customer of them so it's good
stuff whenever I see your a package from
you guys I get so excited because I just
can't wait to see the people and say hey
you got or do like this guy says change
your life delivering a message thank you
very cool very cool on camera what do
you do I own a sewing machine business
and we sell sewing machines and long arm
quilting machines and we have a whole
quilt shop as well and so it's it's
started as about 1,500 square foot and
now I have about 3,000 square foot good
for you the building was actually 5000
square foot that we paid off Oh neat
very fun so that's what this 282,000
that's right the building or the sewing
machine shop I love it so what happened
four years and eight months ago tell me
your story
well you know it actually started much
earlier than that you know we're pretty
frugal people and we've been married for
29 years and so one of the things we
decided to do was to have a garage sale
and in that garage sale I thought wow I
wonder if it would be interesting to see
if people are having an interest in
learning how to use sewing machines
because I have it we both have a
teaching degree as well and so I put a
little notepad out and said hey sign up
if you think you're interested
so my whole notepad was filled in just
that day Wow and so I called the people
up and before you know it I had people
coming down to my basement because I did
not want to open any kind of a store
uptown until I knew for sure that I was
safe and it didn't cost me anything to
have the basement so the next thing you
know they ended up coming down to our
basement and then the next thing they
said is please open a store we need to
buy things so we remodeled the basement
and in 2001 and that's when I started my
business 14 years ago and then it
progressed uptown in 2003 and when we
moved to this building it was a rental
for eight years that we did and then the
building went up for sale and that's
when we decided okay what are we going
to do
I guess we'll buy it so is your home
paid for it is we actually paid the
house off ten years ago okay so you went
back into debt to do this deal four
years and eight months ago you that's
when you bought it so then you decide
we're gonna lean on it and knock it out
now how did you connect up with us well
I've always listened to your a mentor of
mine and we've always practiced your
rules and and and just you know tried to
pay things off we paid with cash and
everything and it just it just worked
out and it was the scariest thing we
ever did though you know because without
a debt and to go into debt again I knew
that was not a good thing and for the
first two years she doubled her payments
and after started the third year -
emotions got me going fear thinking man
I could this is scary and the other one
was anger because I opened a statement
from the bank and it the interest we was
paying was just money throwing we've
thrown out the window which we saw I
thought I got help so okay I made a new
year's resolution every Saturday I'd go
in and put five hundred dollars towards
her building and I did that for two
years and eight months and I missed
three Saturdays and that's how we did it
awesome Wow well congratulations you
guys
it's got to feel good to be clear oh for
sure I mean you know it was so great
when we paid the house off because it
was originally a 15-year loan we paid it
off in 12 and then we decided to buy
this building and you know we scraped up
I mean I I worked really hard in my
store and was able to put a hundred and
twenty five thousand down payment to
make this building and then we decided
we we signed a loan for ten years and
then it was supposed to be renegotiated
after ten years and we said we're not
letting this go this long and so it
became okay work really hard
anything extra we threw out it just got
thrown at it we did it fast that's
pretty impressive well very cool good
job you guys it's a good story all right
David and Tamara Springfield Missouri
our Blake oh those are two hundred and
eighty two thousand dollars paid off in
four years and eight months making
ninety five to 150 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream two one
Oh way to go
fabulous fabulous fabulous fabulous I
love it